Global life expectancy is 74.1 years
But increases in the United States to 78.6,
This is equivalent to 28 thousand and 689 days,
Or 24.787 million seconds of life on earth.
So
What can happen in this period of time?
You produce 0.4 milliliters of saliva per minute
It is 0.5 to 1 liter per day.
This means that you have filled your life for the rest of your life
180 to 360 baths of saliva.
Men cry on average once a month,
The women of Vibein 2.7 times,
This means that the average you cry in your life is 1,745 times.
The average person does not walk an average of 10,000 steps
Because the average of the American adult is 5100 steps a day.
But if it's all about age,
Will reach a record number of 146801 steps.
If the average step length is 0.71 meters,
Then you will walk around the equator about 2.6 times.
Men do not stop producing new sperm.
Men produce between 1 and 10 trillion sperm in their lifetime.
People usually practice sex at the age of 16 to the age of 17.
The boomers were associated with an average of 11 sexual partners,
Millennium babies are expected to be associated
With nearly eight sex partners throughout their lives.
It is estimated that a person from 20 to 60 years of age learns a word or two a day
With a total average of 42,000 words.
This figure declines as we get older
Because this is about the deterioration of our mental powers
At a rate of 5% each contract after the age of forty.
The average person aged 15 or older works 7.9 hours a day in the United States of America,
With a retirement age of 63,
She will spend about 16 years in the office altogether.
But do you really work or do you entertain the comic jokes?
According to one study, young adults use their phones 5 hours a day,
They also scan their phones in 30 seconds at an average of 85 times a day.
When you calculate it you will find that the result is about 13 years spent surfing your phone.
This period does not include Netflix Netflix
Whose subscribers exceed 500 hours
In viewing the content you view annually,
That means you spend about 4.5 years watching Netflix at this rate.
Over the course of your life, you may become a millionaire like a bachelor's degree holder
Who earn an average of 1.8 million
And those with a university degree who earn 1.1 million.
Of your total wealth, you consume alcohol
0.9% of your annual income at $ 515 per year on alcohol.
Men slept about 496.4 minutes daily
Women spend 507.6 minutes,
On average, this means statistically
They are more than 11 minutes away from men,
You spend more than a third of your life asleep.
But even in waking time, we spend 10% of our day with closed eyes.
Because the average person's inclinations reach 28,800 times a day,
Or at a rate of 15 to 20 beats per minute.
By the age of 30, you may get the flu twice every 10 years.
The chances of injury may be reduced due to medical development,
But they may also increase because of the amount of time you spend at home.
A study in the journal "
"We spend 87% of our lives indoors or indoors, while we spend 6% in vehicles.
The Earth stands at 73 billion and 884 million km over the course of your life.
So whatever happens, I have traveled billions of kilometers across space.
This is really fun!
Thank you very much for watching.
You now know what happens during your lifetime
You can also discover what happens within a minute
Via the link you will find at the end of the section
It is also fun
And does not exceed the minute of time actually.
Literally
Subscribe to our channel for more scientific sections
Follow us on Instagram and Twitter
Otherwise we'll see you next week.
Translation: team translate @autrjim